hey I'm Michael Bay and I am a strong
believer in protecting the cinema
experience this is my edit room here in
my house in Miami I love cutting hair
cuz it's quiet this whole system pipes
to Santa Monica where I have five
editors Joe Oh No
bye anyway those are my editors I can
connect it with like different room they
can see what I do on my system here and
we can share screens it's a great way to
work a movie like transformers needs to
be seen using the very finest tools the
best sound technology best projection
technology and cameras I'm here to keep
three-d alive and the only way to make
it the best experience for you is to
shoot it natively that means two cameras
two eyes and see exactly what you're
seeing we're the first movie to ever
shoot IMAX 3d we placed these two
gigantic cameras on top of each other to
give you amazing resolution just like
your eyes you see depth it is beautiful
and it's something you cannot fake we're
gonna spend the extra 10 to 15 million
dollars and we're gonna do it right
we're in fact the only movie this summer
that was shot in native 3d so an image
like this the post convert is virtually
impossible see those billions of little
particles here they have to capture each
one of those and put in a different
space whereas when you shoot it natively
it's already doing that for you
the scale of a Transformers movie is
meant to be seen with big screen
with great Dolby Atmos sound and
brightly lit 3d screens Michael is
always on the cutting edge of technology
for the audience to have them have a
more visceral experience his filmmaking
is a very three-dimensional style
transformers has been a giant part of
our brand it helped build IMAX Michael
is the very first filmmaker to take two
of these cameras and configure them on a
3d rig and shoot in 3d in real time and
that's not trivial the resolution the
detail the clarity it really is
mind-boggling
was a lot of fun to shoot I keep saying
this is my last one and I'm going out
with a bang this is a big scale movie
it is being sent through the ages
without sacrifice there can be no
victory to species at war one flesh one
methyl Optimus Prime has left us 100
billion trillion planets in the cosmos
[Music]
you want to know today why they keep
coming here
[Music]
on a stay
and I want to fight them
now two worlds colliding
the operations over we're not giving up
okay
only one survives
oh my god
forgive me
[Music]
[Music]
this normal kid for my world fell apart
look at me